[Music]
on this friday night the big ask for
this long weekend
stay home and keep your circle tight we
need to act
now we know this is no small sacrifice
the tough new restrictions in parts of
ontario as infections
spread new and apparently improved the
revisions to canada's rent subsidy
program
the nobel peace prize for feeding the
hungry
no one should go to bed hungry much less
starve to death
decades of dangerous work finally
honored
and utterly cute one aquarium's
big attraction
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
lots to get to on this friday night as
we enter the first thanksgiving long
weekend with covid19
the message to everyone is stay home and
keep your circle
small because the forecast is for the
virus to accelerate
we're at a tipping point in this
pandemic not only is the second wave
underway
yesterday we hit the highest daily
recorded cases
well above what we saw this spring
this is the shape of canada's curve
cases slowed over the summer but are now
accelerating and each new case is
spreading the infection
to more than one person people between
20 and 39 still make up the bulk of new
cases but they
are now rising in older more vulnerable
people too
and its forecast cases will keep
climbing unless changes are made
the bottom line we need to reduce our
contacts
in ontario tough new restrictions are
now mandatory as of midnight tonight in
three hot spot regions
toronto peel and ottawa that means no
indoor dining at restaurants and bars
gyms casinos and movie theaters will be
closed as of tuesday all wedding
receptions will be canceled
all of that remains in effect for 28
days
all trends are going in the wrong
direction
left unchecked we risk worst case
scenarios
first seen in italy and new york city
more federal support is on the way for
small businesses caught in the pandemic
restrictions
we'll have more on that in just a moment
but first mike look a tour
and a closer look at where the virus is
spreading and what's being done
to slow it down
it's come to this again restaurant
owners are praying for a pleasant patio
weather because they're being forced to
close indoor dining rooms
for the second time in this pandemic
it's a tough decision to make
but at the end of the day it's public
safety first
you know it really sucks it really does
after weeks of resisting this decision
ontario premier doug ford was briefed
with sobering statistics didn't sleep at
once last night
what ford most certainly saw was where
covid19 is being spread
the latest modeling numbers from the
public health agency of canada show
spikes
in schools and child care centers as
they were reopened
but they were smaller clusters a bigger
concern
is the steady rise in long-term care
facilities and the large number of
outbreaks
related to large indoor gatherings if i
didn't make this decision now
i'd be negligent it was the single
toughest decision i've made
since i've taken office bar none
the good news is that the
hospitalization rate across the country
remains low but that's because of who is
contracting the disease
there's been a bump recently in the
elderly and the overwhelming majority
is in 20 to 39 year olds according to
the numbers from the public health
agency of canada
now in the spring a blanket ban on going
out helped crush
the curve facing an even worse second
wave
the prime minister believes targeted
shutdowns is the way to go
we know a lot more about where
transmissions are happening
what businesses and what activities
create particular vulnerabilities and
that's why
in the second wave we are able to be
more targeted in our approach
that's being coupled with a plea for
people to stay home and stay away from
each other
because health officials say social
circles
were much smaller in the spring now when
the contact traces go out for confirmed
cases
it's in the dozens or even 60 or 70
people and why is that
doctors say those decisions by canadians
weeks ago have led to where we are
today but they have hope that people
will heed the warnings now
to prevent even tighter restrictions in
the future
donna all right mike lucatura thank you
here is the picture across the country
today there were 119
new cases reported in bc 277 in alberta
in saskatchewan today 22 new cases
reported in manitoba 84.
ontario hit a new record 939 new cases
today while in quebec there were more
than
eleven hundred two new cases reported in
newfoundland and labrador and
thirteen in new brunswick two regions of
new brunswick are now moving back into
that province's orange phase the changes
take effect in the moncton and
campbellton health regions
at midnight personal services like hair
salons must close plus gyms casinos and
theaters
people need to stay within two household
bubbles the rest of new brunswick
remains in the yellow phase
alberta is hoping new voluntary public
health restrictions will be enough to
reduce the spread of covid19 in edmonton
there are now more than thirteen hundred
active cases in the region
here's what we know about how people are
getting infected about 36 percent of
positive cases were exposed to the virus
by
a close contact where transmission is
known
household or community contacts appear
to be a key driver in spreading the
virus
throughout the city social gatherings
and family gatherings continue to be a
factor in virus spreading events
alberta's chief medical officer of
health says 26 percent of edmonton's
cases are linked to an outbreak
some have occurred in workplaces where
the virus spread between employees
people in edmonton are now being asked
to wear masks in workplaces
when they can't safely distance and to
limit indoor family gatherings to a
maximum
of 15 people there is a new federal rent
relief program for small businesses in
this country
a replacement for the one that got lots
of complaints the biggest
change business owners can apply
directly and don't have to go through
landlords
david akin breaks down how it works and
who is eligible
the difficult reality is that the health
measures
we are taking to contain covid19
mean there are some businesses that
simply
cannot operate at full capacity
it will be local health authorities that
will order some businesses to close to
try to flatten
canada's cove at 19 curve but it will be
the federal government
backstopping those businesses that get
flattened by those closures
we know the second wave will be even
harder
for those who get hit so the federal
government announced an
improved suite of business support
programs friday
chief among them the new canada
emergency rent
subsidy unlike the previous rent subsidy
program
this one will see money go directly to
commercial tenants
not landlords businesses who have seen
revenues drop by
75 percent can get a subsidy of up to 65
percent
and those businesses that are ordered to
close by health officials
they can get a 90 subsidy of rent and
other expenses
the canada emergency wage subsidy
continues
until next june this one gives employers
up to 65 percent of the wages
that they're paying employees and the
canada emergency business account
is expanded businesses can now get an
additional
interest-free loan of twenty thousand
dollars and for some
ten thousand dollars of that will be
forgiven for a number of businesses
depending on where you're located in the
country you know we're in a second wave
uh depending on what sector you're on
restrictions may have already been
placed or they're starting tomorrow
morning
and one final update on support for
individual canadians
the new simplified employment insurance
system is in place
and the government's new benefit
programs to help those forced to take
sick leave or
needing time off to be caregivers to
children are also
up and running next week applications
will open for the
canada recovery benefit that's a
replacement for the serb
for those like the self-employed who do
not qualify for ei
david aiken global news ottawa
the federal government is also
supporting food banks across the country
another 100 million dollars is being
added to the emergency
food security fund that's on top of the
100 million already invested in the
program in april
the first phase helped provide an
estimated 6 million meals to
2 million canadians in the us covid19 is
now the third
leading cause of death after heart
disease and cancer
according to the magazine scientific
american the virus has killed more
people in the u.s than the flu
stroke alzheimer's and diabetes the
human toll is higher than in any u.s
conflict except for the civil war and
world war
ii since the pandemic began in march the
curve in the u.s
has never really flattened and it
appears to be heading for a third peak
case numbers are climbing again more
than 55 thousand new infections were
reported
today as jackson proskow reports they're
rising so fast some states are running
out of hospital beds
the sprawling line for covid 19 testing
in wisconsin shows a state on high alert
cases are surging hospitalizations have
already soared up 500 percent
in some counties i would say every
hospital is one bit away from being over
capacity some are actually over it
already
the governor has activated a 530 bed
field hospital while bringing in new
restrictions on restaurants and bars
right now in the state of wisconsin we
are in a bad place who's next
it's not just wisconsin the virus is
roaring back across the u.s
with cases on the rise in at least 31
states
parts of new york city have gone back
under lockdown
broadway will stay dark until at least
may
americans are being told to brace for
the extra challenge of flu season no
matter where they live
with predictions the number of deaths
could nearly double to 400
000 by january as we get into the fall
in the winter
it is conceivable if not likely that we
could have
two converging respiratory infections at
the same time
25 days before the election there's
still no clear pandemic message from
washington
the coronavirus positive president
insists he's ready to return to
campaigning
though he struggled to get through a
phone interview thursday night
absentee is okay because absentee
ballots
excuse me there's still no agreement on
a trillion dollar government relief
package as unemployment remains high
i almost accepted i was going to die
caught in the middle are everyday
americans like 19 year old alexandria
rockowski
she spent two weeks in hospital
recovering from kovitt 19
and still suffers from rashes and hair
loss
seven months into the pandemic she's
left frustrated by people and
politicians
who still refuse to play it safe around
the virus
i always say it feels like a slap in the
face it's a lack of empathy
it's heartbreaking jackson prosko global
news
washington as much as we wish it were so
the virus has not
vanished more than 350 000 new cases
were reported across the world
just today that's a new daily record in
england cases are doubling now every
week
french hospitals are beginning to run
out of icu beds
spain has declared a state of emergency
in madrid and as crystal gomencing
reports the fall is going to be full
of tight restrictions
spot checks on the streets of madrid is
police enforce rules in the capitol and
nine neighboring communities traveling
in and out of the city
is not allowed unless it's for work or a
medical appointment
madrid's regional government argues the
travel rules are excessive and hurt the
economy
and they took their argument to court
where they won
prompting spain's national government to
reinstate the emergency act friday
the back and forth left people unclear
of the rules
and frustrated
this man says it's also got to do with
the lack of precautions from citizens
if we had behaved better we would not be
at this point
[Music]
most agree restrictions are needed to
keep hospitals from being overwhelmed
but how best to do that is pitting
regional and national leaders
against one another
german chancellor angela merkel warned
citizens about strict new rules being
considered such as limiting pub
and restaurant hours her house niemann
and
ross merkel however stressed consensus
is needed mayors from the 11 largest
cities
all agreed on the rules that will be
imposed if infections exceed
50 people per 100 thousand
germany has one of the lower infection
rates in europe
the uk has one of the highest it's right
that the government considers a range of
options
to address that and considers all the
evidence but it's also right that they
engage with local leaders and that's
what is happening this afternoon and
over the weekend
more than 108 000 covet 19 infections
have been recorded in the past
seven days and that's with a series of
local restrictions
around britain crystal commansing global
news
london a slam dunk against hunger coming
up a toronto raptor brightening
thanksgiving for hundreds of families
quebec's premier has replaced his
indigenous affairs minister two weeks
after joyce eschequan recorded hospital
staff
saying racist things and insulting her
shortly before she died
ashaquan's death at the hospital in
joliet focused criticism on the fact
that provinces failed to address
systemic racism a former montreal police
inspector is taking
over the indigenous affairs portfolio
this is relation this is trust i'm going
to build that i'm going to start that
today
and people will judge me on my actions
he says his first priority is to talk
with first nations
chiefs new details are emerging about
that alleged plot to overthrow the
michigan state government kidnap the
governor
attack the police and try to start a
civil war the attorney general says
governor gretchen whitmer and her family
were moved around
as law enforcement tracked the men
suspected in the case
at least 13 people including members of
a militia group were charged after the
fbi thwarted the elaborate plot
it's alleged the man spent months doing
firearms training and drills rehearsing
how to snatch the governor from her
vacation home before
the november presidential election
whitner has faced
criticism from right-wing protesters for
measures she imposed
to try to control the spread of the
coronavirus
still ahead new stats on sex assaults
add to calls for
change on canadian campuses
three years into the me too movement
there is still much that has to change
new figures from statistics canada show
11 percent of female post-secondary
students say they've been sexually
assaulted on campus
at canadian military colleges 28 of
female cadets say they've experienced a
sexual assault
the perpetrators were often fellow
students as heather urex west explains
advocates say part of the problem
is the culture at canadian colleges and
universities
cj was 18 when she moved from her home
in saskatchewan
to attend school at calgary's mount
royal university
it was her first time living away from
home
i was learning a lot i had friends
and then yeah it
took a turn cj says she was sexually
assaulted in her
dorm room one night by someone she had
thought of as
a friend she reported the incident to
both police
and school officials but while a police
investigation resulted in a criminal
charge
the school's investigation dismissed her
complaint
it was just devastating like absolutely
devastating
cj's story is not unique this york
university student says
like cj they were sexually assaulted in
their campus residence
with someone they considered a friend we
were friends you know we were good
friends
and the context of the situation was i i
broke up with a partner
and i was very distraught and i went to
him for comfort because i thought i
thought that i could
i think it's really um a continued
concern
that people are experiencing sexual
assault at such high rates there's no
reason why
we can't have great educational programs
run on campus
for young people in particular who are
by and large the ones on campus spaces
to kind of unpack some of the root
causes of gender-based violence and
sexual assault
cj's alleged assault happened in the
fall semester of 2018.
since then mount royal university has
made changes to its sexual assault
policy
the school's new president says its
procedures are more
trauma informed still he admits
there is likely more work to be done i
think the expectations of us are high
and we hate to disappoint and we are
going to continue to do what we can in
order to minimize these kinds of
incidents
but for cj life since the alleged
assaults has been difficult
she dropped out of school soon after her
sexual assault complaint was dismissed
and is now anxiously awaiting the
accused criminal charge to go
to trial she's also looking to the
future
hoping to one day return to
post-secondary school
it's going to be very very hard to trust
people
heather urex west global news calgary
decades of feeding the hungry next this
year's nobel peace prize winner
well we wanted to add a little levity to
your friday evening so
this is me a sea otter at a japanese
aquarium she's learned to
walk on her two hind legs i don't really
have much more to tell you about her
but sometimes no words are needed right
what a cutie well feeding the world's
hungry is what the world food program
has been doing for more than 50 years
it rarely makes headlines but its work
is so vital
as vital as it gets in fact it's kept
tens of millions of people in conflict
zones alive
and it's now being recognized with a
nobel peace prize
eric sorenson explains why
the setting was symbolic and fitting i
can't believe i'm in these
chairs when word came of the nobel prize
the most senior executive of the largest
humanitarian organization in the world
was in niger a poor and hungry country
that gets little attention
but for the selfless often unsung work
of the world
food program i didn't win it you want it
it's
all of us some organizations respond
to sudden catastrophes the world food
program is almost everywhere
all the time in nearly 90 countries
resolutely helping almost 100 million
people in need of food last year
from sudan to somalia to yemen it's
often a vicious cycle
conflict disrupts food supplies then
hunger triggers more conflict
to the nobel committee the world food
program is a force for peace
for acting as a driving force
in efforts to prevent the use of hunger
as a weapon of war and conflict
canada's foreign affairs minister toured
a world food program distribution center
in beirut just six weeks ago
after the devastating explosion the wfp
has praised canada for being the seventh
largest donor in the world
some say canada should contribute more
to foreign aid
though the nobel in effect recognizes
that many nations including this one
do reach out and help this is to
recognize multilateralism
at a time where a lot of countries are
becoming more isolated or isolationist
and to really look at how through
solidarity through cooperation we can
make a difference
hunger though has spread even further
this year because of the global pandemic
the nobel prize draws attention to the
never-ending need for food and security
somewhere in the world alongside
fighting this health pandemic
we absolutely have to prevent a hunger
pandemic and a hunger catastrophe
and this prize bolsters that effort an
effort that carries on
because one in nine people worldwide
still do not have enough to eat
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
friday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with a basketball star
giving back toronto raptor kyle lowry
and his wife are donating 200
thanksgiving hampers to families in need
in toronto
it's the fifth year they've done this
thanks for watching have a lovely and
safe thanksgiving
take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]